now late last month a white female Tech
SEO in Baltimore named pava leer was
brutally beaten and murdered inside her
apartment complex allegedly by someone
named Jason Dean Billingsley and Jason
Dean Billingsley is a black man with an
extensive rap sheet that includes
assault and rape and yet he was still
out on the streets of course but how did
Billingsley get into the apartment
complex well the doors are secure and
only residents can get inside well
according to investigators Le opened the
door for Billingsley and let him into
the building he said that he forgot his
key and she believed him or pretended to
and then after letting him in she got
into an elevator with this ominous
looking guy with neck tattoos a short
time later she was dead on the roof her
body wasn't discovered for several days